e
densification intelligence .
- Saint-Roch-de-l'Achigan,
dans Lanaudière, est l'exemple
parfait de ce que provoque. La ,
à 40 km du centre-villede Montrs
de la Communauté métropolitaine.
Habiter ici coûtedevenu un lieu
de vie recherché par les jeunes
familles et les promoteurs.
SÉBASTIEN MARCIL, maire,
St-Roch-de-l'Achig dis souvent y
a 10 ans, on courrait
après le développement, ici,
à Saint-Roch, mais aujourd'hui,
c'est l'le dévelle dévelle dévet
après. On a 5500 habitants,
puis un moment donné,
le développement, ça commence
quelque part.
- Sébastien Marcil fait partie
d'une nouvelle gééédútioé
fraîchement élue de jeunes
à l'environnement.
On l'a rencontré devant
un développement de maisons
unifamiliales qui avait été
Ce sera un des derniers dans
sa municipalité :
- L'ère du bungalow, là,
c'est terminé. D'abord,
les municipalités, les résultats
sont pas nécessair,
hein, faut vraiment plus
densifier.
général, Vivre en Ville
- Ça imalement
deux fois plus cher faire du
développement en mode étalement
et densification. On est obligés
ruire des autoroutes,
des nouvelles écoles, plus
de tuyaux d'aqueducs, d'égouts.
- À Saint-Roch-de-l'Achig
les bâtiments multi-logements
ont donc commencé à pousser
du territoire de la ville.
- On ne souhaite pas non plus
doubler, tripler la population,
qualité de vie là agricole
t avec.
- L'étalement urbain,
ça nous donne pas grand-chos
les dépenses sont plus hautesmêe
ça reste comme ça.
- On peut en faire encorement uu
plus loin en arrière avecdes qus
de problème. Je veux dire, c'est
qu'il faut pas que, mon Dieuy
vous comprenez? Parce que
ny, avant, c'était tout
petit comme ici!
- La démographie de la couronne
les Laurentides et la Montérégie
comptaie0, 140 000
résidents de plus qu'en 2016.
ALEXANDRE TURGEON, DG Conseil
- Il faut qu'on arrête de
gaspiller notre tee...
Je dirais même, de le scrapper,
de produire des quartiers
dépendants de l'automobile
où les gens ont aucun service
à proximité.
au comité consultatif pour la
'aménagement
du territoire québécois. Vous di
disent "C'est pas pour moi de
vivre dans une zone densifiée,r,
je veux une grosse maison"?
- Bien, moi, je leur dis :
Achetez-en une qui existe.
Puis si la maison
vous plaît pas, démolissez-là
- La clé- La clé- La clé- La clt
d'exploiter les friches urbaines
existantes et de les densifier
de façon intelligente.
Comme icux-Lièvres à Québec.
On y retrouve depu
ce projet vanté par
urbaniste urbaniste urbaniste s
de deux étages habitées surtout
La cour intérieure leur apporte
bien localisé, à deux pasvière .
- On aim Les enfants peuvent
autonome,
en toute sécurité le jour.
Puis, les appartements
pour optimiser l'espace.
le projet, on a oublié
tout de suite l'id
d'un bungalow en banlieue.
Ce qu'on a vraiment cherché,ieux
de travail et limiter
sports quosports quosports quoss
à Montréal, il y a le projetPlan
d'un ancien concessionnaire
automobile dans l'
On y a construit 196 unités,s d.
Il y a un supermarchée-chaussée,
des logements sociaux et,
là aussi, une cour intérieure.aé
métropolitaine de
85 % des unités qui sont
construites sont en multi-
15 % d'unifamiliales, ce qui
démontre
aussi est à la densification
et à la consolidation urbaine.
- Christian Savard souligne
pour du résidentiel n'a été
acceptée
l'adoption du Plan métropolitain
d'aménagement en 2011.
la planification, lorsqu'elle
se donne des dents, fonctionne.
- La densification n'est past ur
les villes; le village
de Saint-Elzéar en Beauce,ent 2,
doit aussi gérer l'arrivée
de nouveaux résidents.
ubles multi-logements
ont commencé à apparaîtr
CARL MARCOUX,
maire de Saint-Elzéar
des terres agricoles, donc,nos t
très importantes pour nous.
Donc, tosion sur esion sur esio,
c'est pas une solution.
- La solution à Saint-Elzéar
est passée par un nouveau schéma
- Tous les nouveaux terrains
en développement p
de promoteurs, la superficie
d'un terrain a été réduite,
L'autre chose, aussi,
supplémentaire pour les terrains
qui sont déjà desservis
- Les mesures commencent
à rapporter. Mais ces maire
maintenant que Québec aural'audé
municipale.
- Il y aans, mais... Demain mat,
une municipalité, moi, comme
maire, là, je décide de protéger
un boisé, économiquement, là,
au contraire, c'est une perte
économiq
longtemps que de scrapper
des terres agricoles et des
plus que de les protéger, un mo,
on a un problème.
- Les rnées 70,
conclut Sébastien Marcil.
Lui, comme les urbanistes
rencontrés, espèrentpour l'envi,
les finances et le
du territoire québécois.
♪ ♪